the Stillness and the peace and the
freedom The Emptiness is not a ground
it's not a place to go and transcend
into or hide from relativity right
tyranny in a way it triggers God's will
for uh transforming Injustice yeah yeah
into Freedom love unity abundance all
these things we've been calling it like
spiritual it's kind of like this
archetype of just like uh transcended
and like like yeah the bypass yeah yeah
yeah just like taking them by the
genitals and like bringing them into
Gaza you know bringing them into the
middle of where there's human rights
violations there's no basic needs being
met people are suffering limbs are cut
off bombs are dropped all this kind of
stuff because it can't live there that
can't live there so it it auto
integrates it's forced to see
what it's actually up against in terms
of healing separation wounds traum
multi-generational traumas of border
conflicts and and so when you look and
you see like two people that are
literally from the same land that have
have had an imaginary border drawn
between them that now hate each other
right that happens everywhere around the
world but that's where all your work
ish that's where all the work is
like it's it's not
like oh it's so good there's nothing
there's nothing yeah yeah and it's like
yeah that is this so great like yeah
let's let's alchemize like the root like
your own root chakra itself is the
center of the Earth where all of the
knot of seeing separation and seeing and
feeling pains and protection and
wounding and hoarding and all kinds of
things like that's where all of the work
is and if you're actually quote
unlimited Consciousness
then you would want to Swan Dive Into
liberating all the limits because you
came here to eat those limits right yeah
yeah